what do our end users actually want are
we making it better
are we building a platform that will
stand up um
what is right what is that what are we
doing why are we doing it how does it
connect to our vision
and then it's ultimately like are we
delivering it
[Music]
i'm so glad to have you here all the way
from
uber trip actions and now loom but and
teach for america before i can't wait to
talk about
product vp of product rules and really
your insights into those various
industries
but before we start on all that i want
to go all the way back to georgetown
you're playing rugby
and how that has you know hinted towards
your life as vp of product
uh i mean i've been a big believer in
team sports my entire childhood so i
played more soccer in my lifetime than
rugby um
and then i went to college and i just
wanted to pick up something new be part
of a team sport
um so i i found myself up
on the rugby team my freshman year
it was super fun i still remember my
first try it was like
i caught the ball and i just remember
the coach be like run run run and i'm
like
i'm running right you have like no idea
what you're doing
you're like i'm gonna do my best i'll be
sprinting
no we don't have much rugby in israel
but rugby is the sport where eventually
just everybody's piling on top of each
other
over this you know cone-shaped ball
right
yeah it's like huge in uh it's huge in
australia and south africa
um it's pretty popular in europe as well
um
but anyways so then after college i
really wanted to do something that
mattered
um and i
just thought teach for america would be
a great place to contribute
i had had the joys of like a great
public education system
um and obviously went to a really strong
private university for college and i
just
i wanted to contribute and i wanted to
do something with high levels of
ownership and something that mattered um
and so
i was lucky to to be selected to be part
of teach for america
so what is teach for america what is the
sort of impact you're trying to make on
the on the public education space
yeah sorry uh that's a great question i
should have started there so teach for
america
is um it's been around for over 25 years
now
um it is a nonprofit that takes high
performing
leaders from quite a bit directly out of
undergraduate university
but some post college and places them
into
high needs school districts um so the
public education system in
in the united states does have a teacher
shortage in a teacher recruitment
shortage
and so partners with high performing
leaders puts them through
a distinct training um and then you are
placed in
in high needs schools so and so what was
your what
what were your various roles because
you've done quite a few things within
teach for america right it's not like
you came in and said
okay i'm going to be a teacher i'm going
to help others in one capacity but you
really branched out and did
quite a few different things and i'm
especially curious for that because
you know looking from your journey from
an outsider you're saying okay you want
to go
study in sort of politics government in
in georgetown then you go into teach for
america and then you find yourself you
know
going straight into high tech at full
speed
both had really big companies like uber
then to medium-sized companies like
hyper growth like trip actions
and now tulum which is more of a startup
scene right so
so i'm really curious to hear about the
journey and how you sort of paved this
road
yeah i mean so a core belief of
of teach for america is teaching as
leadership and i think
that i didn't know at the time that like
learning about teaching and working at
teach for america was preparing me
in many ways for what i do now um learn
how do you get people excited to go
after big goals how do you break it down
into medium goals how do you build a
culture
how do you keep going even when things
get hard
and like the results aren't coming in
and you need to change course
like that is all i mean that is one of
those are some of the many things that
product organizations do
um and it's the same in a classroom and
so i think it was a really good
foundation
in terms of building ownership taking
tough blows
teaching is so hard and then continuing
to keep going
and when i left teach for america i had
joined
the team in dallas and had been working
on developing proof point schools with
like attracting school leaders and high
caliber teachers and in trying to
work with the district to make proof
point schools but
i just wanted to i was really young and
i
you know things were moving really fast
career-wise and i just realized that i
wanted
i wanted to experience something
different i wanted to
challenge my brain in different ways so
i
applied for uber got into uber and then
kind of navigated the company
to get to what i was like ultimately
more interested in which was on the
product side
and then from there i joined trip
actions and the way that i found trip
actions was
i basically went through a process of
like okay who are pcs i believe in
i have to understand the problem like i
want to be
excited by the problem um
and then i met arielle and elon and then
it was kind of off to the races
oh and i had also looked for startups
that had ex-uber
executives i
you know uber is a mixed bag you know
2014 2015 2016 uber there are like
highs and lows from a culture standpoint
but i do think
it was rigorous and bold and
courageous and there were you know
negative attributes as well
that that coin is double-sided um
but i like when
when i first joined there we all
believed in it so much
and i knew that i wanted to work at a
company that that belief
was like fully there
and so then i joined trip actions when
we were 40 people i had no idea
that it would like scale um
and so yeah i was the first product
manager and
amazing so first product manager but
actually pretty quickly then becoming
head of product and then
vp of product and and how many people
were trip actions by the time that you
left
so when i joined we were series a 40
people when i left we were 1200 valued
up
at 4 billion my team went from just me
um to then running the design or really
building the design and product
organization
um to about 27 split between palo alto
and amsterdam
um why amsterdam
uh that was more of an engineering
driven decision
there had been another um well no
amsterdam because
from an operations standpoint we had set
up a support team
okay and then our cto had flown out
there
and had you know met with a startup that
was very talented in the travel space
and so then he made the decision from an
engineering perspective we're gonna hire
there
there's also like a ton of tax
incentives in amsterdam
i think it's it's like amsterdam in
dublin very interesting for startups
um but anyway so it was mostly like
the operations team had set up and then
um our cto had
had gone out and had met like a team of
pretty talented engineers and so then it
just became kind of a natural decision
um also because trip actions is
both a product and an operations company
there's really good views for your tech
team to
be close with the with the support team
or like your operations team um your
customer success team your sales team
there's just a ton of
empathy that's developed um so
it was kind of a win all around both
from a product an engineering and a
support perspective
what were some of the most most
challenging and exhilarating things
about moving
from a you know one person team really
to an
almost a 30 percent team but more
importantly than that
being a part of the incubation of what
will become a 1200 person
4 billion dollar company which i'm
assuming is
as one of the first you know people
working in product in the company
you've gotten to see really the vision
and strategy unfold along the way
as you made those transitions so i'd
love to sort of pick your brain and fast
forward during these years
but really understand what are some of
those insights that you gained
throughout this time i mean i think
the first ones that come to mind and
since you didn't send me the questions
ahead of time i have to just go off the
go
the first is like as you begin to build
a team the
the people you bring in are so exciting
right i think about some of the product
managers that i hired that i meant that
i mentored that i learned from and it
it's just so fun
you know yeah and i think
that is just like a very inspiring piece
of a company growing
and then i think the second piece from a
product perspective that i learned in
spades at trip actions
is like you should always be responding
to the market
right if you want to be winning
um and if you want to be a true partner
to your customers
because trip actions and loom are both b
to b to c like
you need to be both over delivering
and and also have a pulse on how things
are changing
right so how do you then as vp of
products have that pulse how do you
wake up every day and by the way i one
of the questions so before we start you
asking how do you edit these videos what
software do you use
right i mean part i guess that's part of
the the vp product mentality
of constantly doing that market research
but what what is your sort of
engaged responsibility with the market
how do you tangibly go about executing
on it
every single day as you're aligning the
strategy
and when arielle and elon are saying
okay well anyway what is the next
product we should build
then how do you even go about thinking
of that new and innovative vision
that's a good question i mean i think
part of it is
being pretty diligent about always being
in front of customers
so like if i look at weak and i'm not
like in the
field at least twice i'll i'll like pay
customer success in sales and be like
right this is a long week like i need to
get
there and what about what does that mean
anik what does that mean to get in front
of that customer is it literally you
picking up the phone and calling
customers is that
you you know going to meetups and or
rooms
no i push in on customer calls and sales
calls and i also if we're going to lose
a deal
or if this was like if there's something
at risk i
i want to know from it because one it's
my responsibility but also because
there's so much learning
to happen but but i i still about this
you know jumping in
being being responsible them they're
still learning
that's part of both leadership but it's
also a part of
you understanding that it's a process
and you know you have to learn from
every experience
so what from your insights what are some
of the most you know important things
that a product manager
can take with them as they're building
other product and strategy and growing
the ranks as regards to a company's
product
i'm i mean i think the first is like
curiosity
and like i think one of the mistakes
that
product managers that it's funny when i
join
as like a customer into product meetings
that i need sometimes
is product managers being defensive of
their product
uncomfortable right you're like oh it's
criticizing and so that
art of listening with and balancing
being empathetic and being genuinely
curious while also
you know taking ownership and taking
responsibility of the product that
you've developed
um i think it's a really you know it's a
balance that everyone's trying to
to constantly get better at right um and
there's definitely times where i hop off
calls where i'm like i didn't listen
enough or i should have asked more
open-ended questions than i did
um but what is the difference between
open-ended versus closed-ended questions
from a product management perspective so
let's say that i'm now
you know i'm the founder of an early
stage company and i'm trying to get my
validation or i'm trying to get some
insight into whatever i'm building
what would be a dif a key indicator
whether i'm asking the right questions
because i think that that's
both something that i need to get better
at but i think that it's also something
that i see quite frequently
that people don't ask enough open-ended
questions when they're doing their
research
it's like asking uh
do you use x tool versus tell me about
how you
how you edit your videos right you're
gonna get
so much more information you're going to
learn about their workflow
what their tech back is um
and you want to know all of that
information you want to like be
consistently learning about it
because that that will inspire future
decisions
right i think building that gut and that
instinct is so important and we've
talked a lot about customer calls but
it's also like
um you know one of my like
strongest product managers on my current
team is like we should just be using
different video services every week just
like
constantly be like just building our gut
because i i don't think you can be
curious enough
right and also like what are other
products that you're using daily
or that other people are using and what
makes you love them can you be conscious
of that
right signing on to your like we're
using riverside.offset fm
there was i clicked a button and there
was like great user feedback
so i took a picture and screenshoted it
and sent it to pm so that's why it took
me a second to get on right it's like
can you constantly be building that
instinct of what makes great product
because different people are really
strong at different things so it's like
what's going on in the actual market
right like the investor market
competitors
what's going on with your customers your
sales your support team like
make sure you're getting in there and
you actually should be on the calls
and then the third piece is just like
learning from from different types of
products
no 100 and i think by the way the one of
the things that i that i enjoy most
about these open-ended questions
even more than the quantitative
information it's the it's the surprise
element that
that when i hear something that i didn't
expect or that i thought that
that wasn't going to come out of their
mouth and all of a sudden it opens up a
whole new world to me that
if i ask more of a closed-ended question
i'm sort of
bringing my preconceived notions into
the answer and it becomes almost a
rhetorical question where i'm guiding
them towards a specific response
or at least i'm barricading them to some
vertical that they have to you know
that they have to reside in whereas at
the open ended i find that
really i'm getting a breadth of
different world views and
and and things that i really didn't
expect but anika i want to make sure
that we have also enough time
to talk about what you're doing now
because i think that yeah go ahead and i
realized i didn't answer your original
questions i got too excited about the
curiosity
to me it's like in terms of great
product management i think it comes down
to like curiosity leadership
and execution i think that you need all
three of those things
if you have execution without leadership
then the team's not going to be happy
you're only going to execute once
um but those are the three to me and
obviously if you have curiosity but you
don't have the execution
then it's you're going to write some
great confluence papers but you're not
going to end up
building a product people love but anik
today you're you're working as vp of
product
and one of the startups that i enjoy
most mainly because i use it probably 50
or
60 times a day and with pretty much
everything that i do which is
loom loom has developed quite a bit
since i began using it and and
i've been really really enjoying the
product so when you talk to me about
this customer delight and
the the feedbacks that also the user is
getting and you're getting i can really
see that in the product that you're
building there
so as the vp of products tell me a
little bit about what loom
is and what are some of your thoughts
behind
building now a product i i'm pretty sure
on a smaller scale now than
with uber and trip actions right but now
you're but you're seeing that fast
growth
as vp of product yep so loom
is a video messaging product that
essentially allows you to instantly
create a video message and get a link
generated
in and share it to other people and the
reason why i
joined is i had a tremendously difficult
time
giving design feedback to the team in
amsterdam when i worked at trip action
i would sometimes sound like overly
harsh over slack and with time zones
you'd have like
two hours to work and just enabled me
just to create
very quick like feedback yes
and like the intent and the the
effectiveness and the efficiency of loom
was like
just a magical experience um and i think
ultimately
like and then if you ask yourself a few
questions as to like why is it so
effective why is it so efficient
right the purest like the original form
of communication was storytelling
right what are we doing right now we're
just telling stories back and forth
loom is an incredible like product to
put that kind of storytelling that human
voice that efficiency that effectiveness
like in the forefront of of how you work
especially in a distributed work
setting which i think like we all
currently are in and in the future will
be
will be in in a in a totally different
way um
so it's a little bit about lou and a
little bit about what what your role is
vp product is
is it exactly the same responsibilities
you've had in trip actions for example
what are some key differences between
you know that a vp product might have in
one company versus the other because
obviously the title is the same
but i imagine that the scope of
responsibility is pretty different
amongst different organizations
i think the the responsibility between
trib actions and loom feels pretty
similar
uh the major difference is design sits
outside
like we have a a design leader that that
runs
but i think ultimately you know the
responsibility is what are we doing
why are we doing it is it the right
thing right what do we ultimately
believe is our responsibility to
our customers right like what do our end
users actually want are we making it
better
are we building a platform that will
stand up um what is
right what is that what are we doing why
are we doing it how does it connect to
our vision
and then it's ultimately like are we
delivering it are we delivering it by
like
when we said we were going to at the
quality we said we were
um and then how can you build an
organization in a team that is
constantly learning and constantly
improving so we just get better and
better at this dance
right and so you joined loom in august
of 2020
pretty much at some peak of the pandemic
there were so many peaks that
you know every day was almost the peak
of something
in the u.s and so you're
so you joined loom remote collaboration
becoming you know diving deep into this
relatively new industry that is very
different
from from your previous industries and
so what are some of your thoughts behind
you know the remote collaboration
the things that you're observing within
loom that you've gotten to know over the
past i guess
four or five months or so
so i do think there are some
similarities between trip actions and
loom in the sense that they're both b to
b to c
right so either a buyer may be a company
but ultimately
both products rely on your end user
loving it right
and something and that's like kind of
connected to those uber roots and so
being very connected to the consumer is
really important um
but i think you know when i joined loom
i
you know is really excited about the
effectiveness and the efficiency
like bloom can just help people connect
especially like global workforces
i think as i've you know gotten to know
the product and understand joe and
vinnie's fuller vision and experience
the product myself
it's incredible how much the loom
product has the potential to like really
elevate the culture of a distributed
workforce i completely agree
in that cultural aspect and what it can
contribute
it in it makes your culture like more
effective and more efficient
but it also makes the culture like more
rich
more human more lively um
and i i think until
i started using lumen the way that i do
and starting to talk to customers that
are using it in that manner
um it's just an incredible like the
potential of loom is just so
huge and i have to say that i have to
testify to this myself i have quite a
few people that i work with across the
seas in various countries
a lot of them are dependent on my
feedback on a daily basis you know every
few hours
and then the difference between moving
from a slack feedback or a whatsapp
feedback to now me recording a
15 20 second snippet of me demonstrating
on the screen my feedback with my
bubble showing there and me smiling and
talking or even just you know being
casual
it changes the whole relationship it
changes the dynamic and i'm seeing it
just boost the productivity on all
fronts and i think and
again i love what you guys are doing so
thank you for thank you for really
making my work better
and more collaborative and for many of
my friends and colleagues i know that
a lot of people that are using it i i
don't want to take up much more of your
time because i know that you're already
running late to
your next thing but i really appreciate
you taking the time to do this i
my last question which is my favorite
one is three words that you used to
describe yourself
i think my three would probably be
gritty
loyal and adventurous i love it anik
thank you
very very much this was wonderful and
stay safe and stay healthy
so nice to meet you thank you so much
for having me